la journée européenne des langues a lieu
chaque année le 26 septembre et ce
depuis 2001 elle a été créée par le
conseil de l'europe l'occasion de
sensibiliser le public à l'importance de
l'apprentissage des langues et de
promouvoir la richesse culturelle de
l'europe l'institut des langues
étrangères de l'université de versailles
saint quentin a participé cette année à
l'opération jacques pothier aujourd'hui
il y avait des animations du côté de 50
ans et puis à monter également il ya une
antenne de cette université quel est l
objectif pour vous de participer à ce
rendez-vous qui existe maintenant depuis
2001 alors l'objectif c'est bien entendu
de faire connaître à la population et
aux étudiants au premier chef puisque ça
se passe dans les univers dans
l'université et dans ses différentes
antennes les différentes possibilités
d'activités pour approfondir les langues
obtenir des certifications en langue
partir à l'étranger et c'est tout ce qui
a à voir avec l'international puisque en
fait le nom complet de notre institut
c'est institut des langues des études
internationales pourraient tout à fait
que développent les langues et 7
quelques instants sur place dans nos
adversaires d'entreprise oui les
entreprises aussi se tourner vers vers
vous pour leurs salariés tout à fait
puisque non seulement on les forme on
peut former leurs salariés naturellement
aux langues mais aussi à toutes les
implications de la mobilité
internationale et tout ce qu'implique
finalement l'adaptation à une cuma des
cultures différentes et une des
thématiques sur lesquelles on travaille
aussi au niveau recherche puisque comme
on a une université ont fait de la
recherche est ce que justement les
étudiants ou alors les chefs
d'entreprise qui envoient leurs salariés
ou qui eux-mêmes vient de se former sur
plus en plus nombreux
l'émission disaient les français sont
pas forcément de bon élève en tout cas
aujourd'hui c'est la présentation il et
puis c'est vrai que ça change et
souhaité qu' il y ait plus de cours de
langues dans le secondaire
et avec des effectifs qui permette
vraiment aux élèves de s'exprimer à
l'oral on sait que le système français a
tendance aussi à inhiber les élèves qui
n'osent pas s'exprimer de peur d'être
corrigés sur leurs fautes et on essaye
évidemment un autre type de pédagogie
peut voir aussi de revenir en fait sur
des mauvaises des mauvais réflexe qui
aurait été pris et d'encourager le
travail aussi de ballades willencourt à
léser les méthodes tout à fait les
élèves et les étudiants puisqu'on
travaille aussi avec les élèves ont fait
ce qu'on appelle maintenant du moins
trois plus trois c'est-à-dire trois ans
avant le bac et trois ans après le bac
on va regarder tout de même un chiffre
c'est le chiffre d'ailleurs de cette
édition 21,8 pour cent des élèves de
primaire en europe c'est pas seulement
en france mais en europe n'ont encore
aucun enseignement en langue étrangère
c'est un chiffre qui s'est réduit de 10%
en cinq ans mais ça reste beaucoup tout
de même 21 % dans toute l'europe et au
milieu de tout ça les français se
situent plutôt bien est ce que vous
sentez en tout cas un changement est ce
qu'en france les pouvoirs publics voilà
l'éducation nationale change un petit
peu ces méthodes incite à former aux
langues dès le plus dès le plus jeune
âge dès l'école
disons que les efforts sont sans doute
un peu inégaux et que les candidats
qu'ils savaient ou deux ça dépend ça
dépend du type d'établissement
et sans doute de la volonté locale peut
être aussi du dynamisme de la volonté de
pousser ou de soutenir des projets
des académies notamment quels sont les
langues que l'on parle le plus souvent
pour lesquelles en tout cas on vient
vous voir ça reste à l'anglais je vais
vous étonner
surpoids n'est moi c'est l'anglais alors
ça c'est l'anglais et puis l'espagnol en
deuxième langue vêtements et puis
malheureusement pas assez elle passer
l'allemand alors que alors que
l'allemand l'allemagne quand même notre
principal partenaire économique donc il
faudrait on essaye de
stimuler de susciter la poursuite de
l'étude de l'allemand même par exemple
un peu parmi nos étudiants qui
s'inscrivent dans une licence d'anglais
lors on leur propose de continuer à
travailler sérieusement une langue une
langue étrangère secondes et des langues
comme les langues asiatiques et le
chinois par exemple je voulais blob bien
sûr oui on est nécessaire forcément
quelles langues étrangères parlées vous
c'est la question que nous sommes allez
vous poser aujourd'hui dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines moi je parle
aucune langue étrangère je suis très
très nuls en langues alors moi je
parlais tunisiens je parle anglais le
tunisien déjà c'est ma langue maternelle
et paternelle anglais anglais c'est
parce qu en fait j'aime bien j'aime bien
tout ce qui est chansons anglaises de
tout ça donc je vais je vais regarder
les chansons et je traduis les musiques
et c'est avec ça que ça rentre dans la
tête l'espagnol parce que ses origines
espagnoles j'ai essayé l'anglais mais
c'est assez difficile comme beaucoup
j'avais appris l'anglais à l'école mais
j'ai pas tellement continuez donc
j'ai pas pas quoi mon jeu même si je
n'ai pas pratiqué je pense que ça
reviendrait mais bon après voilà tu es
une histoire on n'ose pas trop anglais
très bien un peu d'allemand un peu
d'espagnol voilà c'est tout et je suis
j'aimerais bien pour le chinois
j'aimerais que mon fils après les
chinois parce que c'est la langue du
futur enfin en france on n'apprend pas
bien les langues les profs les parle pas
forcément très bien donc c'est pas enfin
je pense qu'il ya un souci là dessus il
faudrait peut-être développer plus des
profs étrangers qui viennent
apprendre aux gamins par l'étranger
plutôt que des pros français qui
apprennent avec un accent pas génial je
pense qu'avant de parler bien le
apprendre parler une langue étrangère
pourrait déjà que les gens parlent bien
français qu'il écrivait qu il le parle
ça serait déjà très important avant
d'apprendre l'anglais l'italien et
l'allemand hanf un poids en moins
le français forcément et puis les autres
langues aussi un jacques pothier donc
l'institut des longues études
internationales à l'université de
versailles saint quentin vous parler
quelle langue l'anglais naturellement je
suis professeur d'anglais mais
l'espagnol aussi et vous apprenez
d'autres langues dont justement dans le
cadre de l'institut 10 allawi avait
samedi un nom moi non je le peuple je
peux vous dire oui mais l'autre côté ce
qui est une offre abondante donc que je
vais bien tout à l'heure dans le micro
trottoir on en entendait parler
également des méthodes les méthodes
d'enseignement des professeurs qui sont
peut-être pas assez fort mais il
faudrait peut-être des professeurs
étrangers qui viennent en france pour
apprendre aux élèves quelles sont vos
méthodes alors on a des méthodes très
très très très diverses et qu'on va
adapter aux différents publics c'est à
dire que par exemple les certains des
interviews world là qu'ils avaient envie
de se remettre aux langues et qui avait
des mauvais souvenirs on va on va les
recevoir et puis les écouter et puis de
leur proposer un ensemble de type
d'exercice ou de formation qui leur
parle d'expérience qui vont leur
permettre de vraiment profiter de ce
qu'on dise qu'on peut leur offrir ça
peut être par exemple du travail sur sur
des plateformes électroniques ça peut
être du travail sur avec des classiques
laboratoire de langues goudé pour vous
adapter en fonction du ou des eaux des
ateliers de conversation avec des
knights pickles stanford et
des locuteurs natifs puisqu'on est dans
une université on a beaucoup d'échangés
internationaux donc on a comme tuteur
des étudiants deux de ces pays là et ces
étudiants étrangers ils viennent aussi
vous voir pour apprendre éventuellement
déjà le français l étude voir d'autres
langues mais ce qu'ils sont à l'aise
avec les langues étrangères les ateliers
vous avez proposé cet après midi dans le
cadre de cette journée européenne des
langues étrangères eh bien il était
destiné aussi à ses étudiants étrangers
anthony rech et puis david sharp en ciel
les ont rencontrés cet après midi les
petits grains blancs vous savez comment
ça ça s'appelle
aoun connaisez palme aux séries du riz
et y y
et z à la grammaire française
la hantise des enfants à l'école ces
cours qui n'en finissent pas où l'on se
dit que notre langue est trop compliqué
mais tout le monde n'est pas allergique
lors de la journée européenne des
langues les étudiants étrangers s'y
colle avec plaisir par de petits
ateliers c'est l'occasion pour eux
d'apprendre de nouveaux mots polex un
bon et je ne connais pas un vain
le crime et
pour les étrangers le plus compliqué est
de faire la différence entre
prononciation et transposition sur la
feuille
pourquoi essayer dur c'est la langue
française qui est compliqué et oui c'est
un peu compassé
si tous
les pales
appris comment j'ai l'église
contrairement aux français les étrangers
sont pleins d'enthousiasmé lorsqu'il
s'agit de grammaire française sont très
motivés parce que déjà il est pour
beaucoup c'est un rêve de venir en
france
quelques mois donc quand ils sont là ils
ont envie de tout faire pour apprendre
un maximum il ya tous les niveaux en
fait y en a qui arrivent qui parlent pas
un mot il y en a qui arrivent qui parle
très bien français donc voila mais la
progression en général est assez rapide
certains sont plus à l'aise à l'écrit
comme les chinois et inversement les
espagnols et les italiens très bavard
nous ressemble le sert elle le centre de
ressources et espace langue ouvre ses
portes le vendredi 28 septembre il
permet l'apprentissage d'une dizaine de
langues étrangères
donc on l'a entendu ça sera également
ouvert le 28 vous validez ce reportage
c'est le très bien alors on va pour ça
de s'intéresser juste pour conclure à
ses étudiants étrangers est ce qu'ils
apprennent plus facilement une autre
langue et notamment le français
forcément est-ce qu'ils ont plus de
facilité que les études les étudiants
c'est très difficile de comparer je
voudrais juste rajouter un petit détail
c'est que le sert elle est installée
dans plusieurs lieux puisqu'on est à
trois points du aux trois coins du
triangle des yvelines où il peut presque
partout dans le département comme
partout dans le département n'est donc
aussi à nantes et à versailles ton qu'on
a on a trois céréales orge et
d'étudiants étrangers est ce qu'elle se
débrouillait ce qu'ils se débrouillent
mieux parce qu'ils ont des facilités ça
dépend beaucoup des étudiants les
étudiants pas une question de culture
aussi voilà d'apprentis c'est facile on
a moins peur de ça alors il ya des
raisons je dirais technique assez précis
c'est à dire que certaines langues ont
des fréquences d'un éventail de
fréquences qui est différent à l'oral
donc ça permet une meilleure une
meilleure meilleure saisie de la langue
orale lors que le français est à s'est
écrasé dans les gammes de fréquence donc
ça c'est une raison technique et
phonétique en quelque sorte
et puis il ya des habitudes culturelles
c'est à dire que dans les pays nordiques
comme comme on sait généralement les
étudiants ou les jeunes d'ailleurs les
très jeunes sont exposés aux langues
étrangères très tôt de différentes
manières d'abord parce qu'ils peuvent la
prendre à l'école et puis en plus de ça
par exemple parce que beaucoup de films
qui passent à la télévision ou au cinéma
sont en version originale sous titrée ce
qui est moins c'est une exposition
extraordinaire et ça effectivement c'est
on ne peut trop encourager alors c'est
je fais pas je fais pas de la bonne pub
publicité pour ce que je vends mais il
ya une méthode gratuite de s'améliorer
en langue c'est déjà d'écouter les films
en version originale
voilà déjà un conseil que vous pouvez
appliquer facilement chez vous merci
jacques poitiers d'être revenu sur ce
monde à tournon directeur de l'institut
des longues études internationales
université de versailles saint quentin
puisqu'aujourd'hui 26 septembre c'était
la journée européenne des langues
étrangères vous disposez d'un site
internet bien évidemment si on veut
avoir plus d'informations on va passer à
la culture à présent johanna soudry elle
va me rejoindre comme chaque mercredi
juste le temps de se rendre à elancourt
où l'on entretient le patrimoine de la
ville elle les amis est du passé cultive
la vigne depuis des années les
traditionnels venge en danger c'était le
week-end dernier
spectacle improbable en ile de france
dimanche les élans courtois ont
participé aux vendanges à la ferme du
mousseau nous avons replanté des pieds
ding il ya 22 ans car il y avait
autrefois plusieurs pieds de vigne
plusieurs vignobles en ile de france et
est le plus grand en france et puis là
c'est pour créer recréer un événement
festif pédagogique ludique la vigne est
entretenu à l'année par une équipe de
vignerons dont fait partie roland
chevalier alors quelles sont les
différentes étapes avant de pouvoir
récolter ont taillé au mois de février
on va tailler la au mois de février
cette ville ensuite dans le reste de
l'année on entretient les pieds on bin
on aère bon le raisin commencent à
fleurir à être en grappe à ce moment là
on coupe les gourmands parce que les
gourmands dépasse la mine largement et
ce à plusieurs fois viennent ensuite les
vendanges qui ont été avancées de 15
jours cette année parmi les vendangeurs
on retrouve des habitués comme mélissa
et ses quatre enfants qui participent
depuis trois ans elle est
on trouve ça sympa de voir comment faire
le jus de raisin de rencontrer les gens
du village parce qu'on est du village
cette année les vendangeurs ont ramassé
50 kg de raisin blanc et 150 de raisin
noir grâce auquel on produira environ
120 le trou de balle et le jeu de réseau